hey really quick you should check out
our sponsor the Janus SmartWatch
designed by Kronos blade I love mine you
can download any Android app make phone
calls watch videos track your heart rate
it has GPS it has a dual camera for
pictures videos and video calls and one
of the biggest screens out there 1.6
inches
check it out using the link right below
ok we are about to see true what I call
c-span porn tomorrow c-span isn't
normally the place for high ratings and
exciting television but it's usually
instead a place for endless government
testimony of all kinds but tomorrow we
might actually have arguably the most
anticipated c-span type testimony before
elected officials certainly in a very
long time and by far within the trump
presidency I think a close second will
be Michael Cohen's testimony some months
ago I expect former special prosecutor
Robert molars testimony tomorrow to be
extremely extremely noteworthy and
newsworthy you will recall that Robert
Muller filed a report summarizing his
investigation into Donald Trump and in
that report not only did he say he
couldn't exonerate Donald Trump of
obstruction actually clarifying if we
could have exonerated him we would have
said so
he actually indicated that on 14
possible counts of obstructive acts by
the president all three legal
requirements to be criminal obstruction
were met on eight of those 14 possible
obstructive acts and he is going to be
testifying tomorrow and Donald Trump is
truly panicking we don't know what
Muller is going to say but even if he
merely states in clear terms what's in
the report it is going to be devastating
to Donald Trump insofar as millions of
Americans have no idea what's in the
report I've talked about this before
William bar in advance of the release of
the Moller report put out this
propaganda letter a very calculated
political document which was then used
by Trump and the people around him to go
on a national exoneration to her
claiming no collusion no obstruction and
of course then the actual report came
out doesn't match in almost any way
when you look at the bar letter you if
you've really read the molar report you
would say the bar letter can't possibly
be a about the molar report can it
because it bears no resemblance to the
content of the molar report and that is
why millions of Americans who are just
busy living their lives working their
jobs earning their widely stagnant wages
and bringing their kids to school
haven't read the molar report and so if
molar shows up tomorrow and is just
asked about the contents of the report
and explains what's in there that alone
will be devastating to Donald Trump
never mind the fact that we might learn
about so many other things that didn't
make it into the report so Trump clearly
panicking starts tweeting yesterday that
Robert Muller simply shouldn't be
allowed to testify at all saying quote
highly conflicted Robert Muller should
not be given another bite at the Apple
in the end it will be bad for him and
the phony Democrats in Congress who have
done nothing but waste time on this
ridiculous witch-hunt result of the
Moller report no collusion no
obstruction so there are five lies at
least that I count in this short tweet
by Donald Trump which is sort of amazing
right the economy of words with which
the president can tell so many lies
he says highly conflicted Robert Moeller
molar is a Republican and there's no
evidence of any conflict number two that
molar shouldn't be given another bite at
the Apple implying that the testimony is
a way for molar to get Trump indicted
that's not what the testimony is lie
number three it will be bad for molar
molars in his 70s and retired I don't
think it's gonna do much for molar
either way line number four calling this
a ridiculous witch hunt there have been
more than a dozen indictments including
top trump staffers going to prison plus
evidence in molars report of obstruction
by the President of the United States on
eight counts doesn't sound like a witch
hunt and lie number five molar said no
collusion no obstruction of course
untrue Muller said he could not clear
Trump of obstruction and found evidence
of obstructive acts on eight of the 14
possible counts five lies in such a
short tweet but the most disturbing
thing about this is not actually the
lies in a sense we've kind of become
- lies the most disturbing thing here is
Trump suggesting that Muller shouldn't
be allowed to testify there's no legal
justification for not allowing Robert
Mulder to testify
I don't believe Trump understands how
guilty and insecure he looks when he
does this even though to his followers
it doesn't really matter they fall for
the fake news witch-hunt talking points
no matter what but this is why it's
imperative that Robert Muller testify
this is why it's so important that the
content of the Moller report is
published so that clear-thinking people
who again they're not avoiding the
Moller report per se they heard about
the bar letter they're busy working
they're busy raising kids they're living
their lives they simply haven't read the
Muller report and don't know what's in
it
he must testify so that more Americans
hopefully millions or tens of millions
of Americans are exposed to the factual
empirical content of the report Trump's
only objection to Moeller's testimony in
reality is Muller testifying has the
potential to be really really bad for me
me being Trump that cannot be allowed to
silence people
we'll be watching tomorrow for sure I
hope that there's no funny business in
the very end in the run-up to this
testimony because it's extraordinarily
important and I look forward to seeing
it and we'll be covering it on the show